Obi-Wan Kenobi's whole existence in the Star
Wars universe is tied up with the fate of Anakin
Skwalker — and their history is even longer
and more complicated than you might think.
This is Obi-Wan's history
with Darth Vader explained.
In The Phantom Menace, Obi-Wan tells his master,
Qui-Gon Jinn, that he senses they've "picked up
another pathetic life form," referring to the
young Anakin Skywalker. This line demonstrates
how, from the very beginning, Obi-Wan didn't
think they needed extra baggage on their quest to
stop the Trade Federation's invasion of Naboo. In
fact, Obi-Wan and Anakin never seem to gel in The
Phantom Menace. As Qui-Gon waits to hear if the
Jedi Council will accept Anakin as an apprentice,
Obi-Wan even points out that his master's defiance
is preventing his promotion to the Council itself.
Obi-Wan strictly adheres to the Jedi code and
takes issue with Qui-Gon's constant rebellion
against it. However, when Qui-Gon is killed by
Darth Maul, his dying request is that Obi-Wan
train the young Anakin. Obi-Wan himself briefly
takes on Qui-Gon's rebellious spirit when he
tells Yoda he will train Anakin to fulfill this
wish, regardless of whether the Council approves.
Obi-Wan's general fidelity
to the Jedi Order and its
rules frequently contrasts with the older
Anakin's perpetual rebellion against them.
However, the decision to go against the Council
in the first place is handed down by Qui-Gon,
who planted a seed for the rift that
would one day tear the galaxy apart.
From the start, Anakin Skywalker is depicted as a
man of action, while Obi-Wan is a more careful and
analytical fighter. A perfect example of this
takes place in Attack of the Clones, when Anakin
rushes in to fight Count Dooku, only to be knocked
out by his enemy's Force lightning. Meanwhile,
Obi-Wan chooses to take a more defensive approach
— and lasts longer in battle because of it.
While Anakin is seen as something of
a prodigy, his reckless actions often
lead Obi-Wan to regard his apprentice
with exasperation as well as admiration.
In the Clone Wars series, Obi-Wan
frequently scolds Anakin for being too
fool-hardy while Anakin often calls
out Obi-Wan for being too hesitant.
"We don't need a whole
fleet, I can do this myself."
"Anakin, slow down and do what I tell you. It's
more important to save lives than destroy ships."
Anakin leaps into battle without thinking
about it and, thanks to his abilities,
always makes it out on the other side. On
the other hand, Obi-Wan always tries to
evaluate every situation in order to come up
with a proper plan. Of course, it's Anakin's
reckless need to take action that eventually
leads him to the dark side. No doubt the older
Obi-Wan would have wished that he had taken this
character flaw of Anakin's far more seriously.
A key facet of the Jedi code is
that Force users should always avoid
personal attachments. Anakin shows us why
this principle is so important because his
love of Padmé allows Palpatine to manipulate him
into joining the Dark Side. However, Anakin's
attachment to his relationships isn't exclusive
to Padmé. It also includes Obi-Wan himself.
"Obi-Wan is a great mentor, as wise as
Master Yoda and as powerful as Master Windu."
Attack of the Clones demonstrates how deep their
relationship goes when Anakin sees Obi-Wan come
under attack by droidekas. Anakin had earlier
pointed out that Obi-Wan is the closest thing
he has to a father, and he clearly wants
to save him from the droids — but he's torn
between that desire and his duty to protect
Padmé. Thankfully, Padmé actually suggests
trying to save Obi-Wan themselves, giving Anakin
the opportunity to set out to rescue his master.
Of course, it is this shared mission
that cements Anakin and Padmé's love.
After their rescue mission fails and the two are
sentenced to execution in a gladiatorial arena,
they share a kiss that later leads to marriage.
Anakin's inability to deny his personal
relationships is a flaw in his Jedi mindset that
recurs throughout the prequel era, eventually
leading to his fall from grace. His affection
for Obi-Wan is a central issue in this dynamic,
making the history that Anakin, Padmé,
and Obi-Wan share a very dangerous thing.
The Phantom Menace ends with Obi-Wan as a full
Jedi Knight and Anakin as a Padawan. A decade
later, Attack of the Clones ends with Anakin's
marriage and the beginning of the Clone Wars.
Following that, The Clone Wars covers the
three-year gap between Attack of the Clones and
Revenge of the Sith. Given the amount of ground
the series covers, it has to be inferred that,
when the First Battle of Geonosis takes
place and the war begins, Anakin is
immediately promoted to Jedi Knight, as both
he and Obi-Wan are generals in The Clone Wars.
From that time on, Obi-Wan and Anakin are seen
as colleagues on more or less the same level,
and they are generally given the same
level of responsibility in most situations.
It's worth remembering, however, that
not only had Anakin just been promoted,
but he started his training considerably later
in life than most Jedi. If Anakin had bristled at
Obi-Wan's instruction before, no doubt he really
resents any perceived seniority by this point.
Obi-Wan, however, never seems to begrudge the
fact that Anakin skips ahead to become his equal.
Anakin Skywalker was supposed to be Obi-Wan's
student, and you would expect a master and
student relationship to continue in some shape
or form even after their formal training ends.
That certainly seems to be the
case with Yoda and his students,
as even Count Dooku views his old master with
respect. Yet, perhaps because of Obi-Wan and
Anakin's closeness in age, their equal
military ranks, and Anakin's exceptional
strength with the Force, they become more
like brothers than a student and a teacher.
By the time Anakin is a full-fledged Jedi, he
already seems to think of himself as superior
to his master. Obi-Wan is constantly advising
prudence, while Anakin almost always thinks
immediate action is the key to victory. This
difference leads to competition between the two
as they seek to prove that their approach is
better. Anakin is especially eager to prove
that he's stronger than Obi-Wan, culminating
in their duel on Mustafar, in which Obi-Wan
insists Anakin can't defeat him. The younger Jedi
acts rashly and is left for dead as a result,
putting a final end to their
long and fateful sibling rivalry.
Anakin tends to think that Obi-Wan is
a model of self-control, to the point
where he mistakes Obi-Wan's adherence to the
austere Jedi lifestyle for a lack of emotion or
passion. Yet we see in The Clone Wars that
Obi-Wan understands Anakin's longings more
than Skywalker seemed to realize.
He simply doesn't give in to them.
Take, for instance, Obi-Wan's history with Satine
Kryze, the ruler of Mandalore. Their relationship
parallels the dynamic between Anakin and Padmé,
as Satine is also a strong woman and political
leader. One Clone Wars story arc reveals that
she and Obi-Wan once had a romantic connection,
though it's never clear if they
acted on those feelings. However,
it's obvious Obi-Wan cares for her, and
perhaps if he and Anakin had discussed
their forbidden romances it would have helped
steer Anakin away from his eventual downfall.
Despite what Anakin might think, Obi-Wan also
questions the Jedi Order from time to time.
This is first seen when he tells Yoda he
will train Anakin no matter what the council
decides — but it is also made apparent with
his reaction to the Jedi Order's vilification
of Ahsoka Tano for a crime he knows she did not
commit. The real difference between these two
Jedi is how they handle their issues with the Jedi
Order. For all his power, Anakin never learns to
control his emotions the way Obi-Wan does, despite
Obi-Wan's pleas for his former Padawan to do so.
In Attack of the Clones, Anakin angrily complains
to Padmé that Obi-Wan is jealous and holding him
back. Of course, this isn't the case at all.
Obi-Wan only ever wants the best for Anakin,
believing that, despite the boy's exceptional
skills with the Force, his Padawan needed to
mature emotionally in order to become a full
Jedi Knight. Obviously, Obi-Wan was right.
Several times in The Clone Wars, Obi-Wan
tells Anakin to play a situation carefully,
only to watch as Anakin rashly springs into
action. Sometimes it works out, but other
times his brash choices lead to high casualties,
or to Obi-Wan having to rescue the young Jedi.
What Anakin sees as Obi-Wan's jealousy is
actually his master's desire to guide him to
reach his full potential. Eventually, when Obi-Wan
confronts Darth Vader, the former apprentice
tells Obi-Wan not to lecture him, insisting
that he sees through the lies of the Jedi.
By extension, he claims to see through the
supposed lies that Obi-Wan had told him to keep
him from fulfilling his destiny. It's a tragic
misinterpretation of their entire relationship.
In A New Hope, Obi-Wan says
this of Anakin Skywalker:
"He was the best star-pilot in
the galaxy and a cunning warrior."
More importantly, though, he adds:
"And he was a good friend…"
Anakin's inability to identify and control
his emotions was a weakness that Palpatine
easily exploited. On the other hand, Obi-Wan
may have felt a more profound love for Anakin
than his apprentice felt for him, simply
remaining in control of those feelings.
Obi-Wan's heart breaks when he watches the
security footage of Anakin killing younglings,
and on Mustafar, Obi-Wan laments that
he has failed his young apprentice.
Obi-Wan retreated to the life of a hermit
in order to hide from the Empire after the
destruction of the Jedi Order, but you can't
help but wonder whether he also exiled himself
as punishment for preventing Anakin from falling
to the dark side. When Obi-Wan appears in Rebels,
a deep sadness lingers over his bittersweet
victory against his longtime rival, Maul.
In A New Hope, Darth Vader says that he feels
Obi-Wan's presence on the Death Star, so there
can be doubt that Obi-Wan knew Vader was there as
well. He chooses to go alone on his mission, in
part because the ever-contemplative Obi-Wan knows
he will have to confront his former apprentice.
Looking at their final showdown from this
point of view, it is a reasonable conclusion
that Obi-Wan believes his sacrifice to
be penance for failing his old friend.
After Anakin becomes Darth Vader, Obi-Wan
volunteers to watch over Luke on Tatooine.
He didn't have to do this, however.
Obi-Wan could have left Luke to be
raised by the Lars family alone.
Of course, he takes this mission
in part out of a desire to see a Jedi
re-emerge and save the galaxy. However,
another part of him probably wants to protect the
son of a friend he once cared very deeply for.
When Obi-Wan tells Luke about his father in
A New Hope, he hides the true nature of his
relationship to Darth Vader, telling Luke that
Vader betrayed and murdered Anakin Skywalker.
In Return of the Jedi, Obi-Wan famously claims
that Anakin ceased to exist once he became Vader,
and that what he told Luke was
true from a certain point of view.
It stands to reason that Obi-Wan would have
held onto his feelings for his lost brother,
and that he probably saw it as his
duty to watch over and protect his son.
It's a well-known fact that Obi-Wan
won his victory over Anakin on Mustafar
because of his ability to claim the
high ground. This slight difference in
elevation allows Obi-Wan to slice off Anakin's
limbs after he attempts to go for the kill.
However, this line applies to more than just the
physical difference between the two Jedi. Obi-Wan
has also gained the moral high ground here,
and it's hard to argue otherwise — especially
considering that Anakin has just destroyed
the Jedi Order he was sworn to protect,
slaughtered the younglings,
and attacked his own wife.
Throughout the prequels and the series,
Obi-Wan has a firmer grasp of morality
and duty than Anakin, who often acts for selfish
reasons. And while more stories in the Star Wars
galaxy may find Obi-Wan struggling with the
moral ambiguities of life outside the order,
he will no doubt always keep the high
ground over his former apprentice.
Check out one of our newest
videos right here! Plus,
even more Looper videos about your
favorite movies are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one.